World Press is analyzing the conflict in
Sudan from many angles
from competition for mineral wealth and
fertile land to ethnic tensions bitter
political disputes and other countries
wanting a piece of the economic pie
today we're looking at articles in the
financial times the Middle East eye and
the guardian which we'll begin with well
this article is quoting former
ambassadors and analysts who say Sudan
has been providing food security to
Nations across the world for years
and after the 2019 Uprising that ousted
Omar al-Bashir Gulf countries the US and
Europe swept in eager to deepen
Financial gains it goes on to say the
United Arab Emirates fostered a close
connection with Muhammad alhamdulo
that's hametti whose rapid support
forces control the majority of Sudan's
gold mines and that the uae's partners
intervened to protect their interests It
quotes American officials as saying
Libyan General Khalifa hafta helped to
train the rsf while the Wagner group a
Russian private military force
reportedly offered weapons
it ends with a comment by former USM voy
Jeffrey feltman who says if you stop the
fighting then you eliminate the breeding
ground for outside interference
and in another article in the Financial
Times by the Africa editor David pilling
who says
this town ain't big enough for the both
of us using it to describe the two
generals as Gunslingers vying for
control of what's left of Sudan pilling
argues The Reckless disregard for life
is symbolic of a wider betrayal that the
2019 Revolution he recalls a sense of
optimism and hopes for a better Sudan
where everyone will have a seat at the
table but when it came to putting down
their guns he said the generals had too
much to lose and eventually reneged on
Democracy while pilling's final point is
not to say that Africans are any more
prone to corruption or making any
excuses for the coup leaders but
transitioning to something better is
devilishly difficult
and finding an article from the Middle
East eye that focuses on the dire food
and Medicine shortages
it says customers complain about empty
shelves and exorbitant prices while shop
owners say the increase of the cost of
fuel and transport has forced them to
increase prices
the authors do mention local initiatives
including a food bank run by young
people and one of the interviewees is a
doctor who has built a 1 200 member
WhatsApp community in Khartoum and
umderman where people can share
information about where to find basic
items well that's our press review for
the day but we'll keep delving into
those newspapers and dailies who
continue to cover the conflict as it
unfolds